so someone made a comment on one of my
youtube videos recently
and they said my grandfather ate bread
sugar
and drank alcohol whiskey his entire
life
even smoked and he lived to be over 90
years old
so how do you explain that dr berg i
thought that if we consume these
foods we're supposed to die early
well here's the thing everyone comes
into this world with a different package
different genes different family
histories
so if you had several generations before
you
that really took care of their bodies
they ate healthy
consume food from fertile land
you're going to probably end up with
some pretty robust genes
because there wasn't a lot of things to
weaken those genetics
so you probably could then be the person
who gets away with it
there are certain countries that have
perfect bone structure and teeth like in
africa they live off food
that is grown on volcanic
soil so you get all these amazing trace
minerals that build
really healthy bone structure then you
have other countries that produce
different types of foods that you end up
with a lot of
teeth decay like in the uk there's a
tremendous amount of
sugar refined foods and and dental
issues
same thing with the us so depending on
your genetics your family history
the foods the country that you live in
it can make a huge difference of where
you are on the spectrum
but the great majority of people
unfortunately develop
metabolic diseases earlier and
earlier but there's usually a point in
someone's life a time that things start
to break down
for me it was 28 years old you see
before that i could eat bread and i ate
a ton of bread
a ton of sugar and i definitely drank
alcohol and i had
absolutely no symptoms whatsoever i felt
great so i can get away with it and
that's why i had no attention on it i
didn't want to change because i felt
fine at that point in my life you
couldn't educate me
about keto or cutting off carbs because
i didn't i wasn't fat i felt great i had
no problems until
28 years old and then i started to
really start to go downhill
and that's when i started to make some
changes so there are several factors
that would determine if this is 28 years
old
or earlier or a lot later that would be
your genetics how robust your genes are
from your family tree then you have
epigenetics the environment
what happens in the environment your
eating habits
your stress level pollution there are a
lot of factors
that are epigenetic factors which are
basically even above
the genetics what happened with me when
i was 28 is i went through tremendous
stress right before that
going through school and and starting
out in practice
and i know that did not help compounded
by the fact that i was eating completely
refined empty calories without
any type of vegetables whatsoever or
anything nutrient dense
and then you have your health reserve
how much reserve do you have
and then your attitude which is another
factor which is very very very
important probably should be at the top
of the list
you have some people that are so
positive they're so
up that they never get sick
so this is a really important factor as
well
all right there you have it that's my
response to this question
before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help